THINGS ARE GOING TO CHANGE
SUBSTANTIALLY IN THE FIRST
COUPLE OF WEEKS AND AS WE GET
INTO THE MIDDLE OF JANUARY.
>> I THINK IT'S WELCOME NEWS
THAT THINGS WOULD CHANGE IN
JANUARY BUT THAT DOES MISS WHAT
A CRITICAL PERIOD RIGHT NOW
WHERE PEOPLE ARE TRAVELING TO
SEE FAMILY, HOPING TO GET
TOGETHER FOR THE HOLIDAYS FOR
NEW YEAR'S EVE SO WHY AREN'T WE
THERE RIGHT NOW TESTING?
>> YOU KNOW, TESTING HAS ALWAYS
BEEN AN ISSUE, KAITLYN, THAT HAS
BEEN PROBLEMATIC.
IT HAS BEEN COMPOUNDED BY THE
SITUATION OF THE HIGH DEMANDS.
WE HAD A CONFLATION OF HIGH
DEMANDS BECAUSE OF THE CONCERN
ABOUT OMICRON, WHICH IS A
JUSTIFIABLE CONCERN, BUT THE
HIGH DEMAND THAT WAS TRIGGERED
BY THE HOLIDAY SEASON, PEOPLE
GETTING READY TO TRAVEL, GETTING
READY TO MIX WITH FAMILY MEMBERS
AND FRIENDS HAS BEEN A VERY,
VERY STRONG RUN ON TESTING, AND
YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY NOT MAKING
ANY EXCUSES FOR IT, WE SHOULD
HAVE HAD MORE TESTS AVAILABLE
BUT HOPEFULLY NOW AS WE GET INTO
THE FIRST COUPLE OF WEEKS IN
JANUARY, THAT WILL GET MUCH
BETTER.
>> I DO WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT A
TREATMENT AS WELL THAT THE FDA
AUTHORIZED LAST WEEK THE FIRST
PILL FOR COVID-19 WHICH IS A
VERY HIGHLY EFFECTIVE DEFENSE
AGAINST SEVERE ILLNESS WHICH IS
OBVIOUSLY GREAT NEWS BUT THE
WHITE HOUSE SAYS THERE'S ONLY
GOING TO BE 265 TREATMENT
COURSES OF PFIZER AVAILABLE NEXT
MONTH.
SO HOW LONG DO YOU THINK IT'S
GOING TO TAKE UNTIL THAT PILL IS
WIDELY AVAILABLE TO EVERYONE IN
THE UNITED STATES?
>> WELL, WE HAVE AN ORDER AND A
COMMITMENT FOR 10 MILLION
TREATMENT COURSES.
THAT UNFORTUNATELY, KAITLYN, IS
GOING TO TAKE A FEW MONTHS
BEFORE WE GET TO THAT NUMBER AND
THE REASON IS THAT THE SYNTHETIC
PROCESS OF MAKING THIS IS VERY
COMPLICATED AND A MULTISTEP
PROCESS THAT IS VERY DIFFICULT
TO CUT DOWN ON THE TIME FRAME OF
GETTING HIGH QUANTITIES.
WE ARE GOING TO DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN, INCLUDING THE DEFENSE
PRODUCTION ACT, TO TRY AND SEE
IF WE CAN ACTUALLY GET THIS AT A
HIGHER LEVEL.
WE ARE NOT SURE WHAT WE CAN DO
AND HOW MUCH TIME WE CAN CUT OFF
ON THAT BUT CERTAINLY IT NEEDS
TO BE DONE, BECAUSE IT IS A
HIGHLY, HIGHLY EFFECTIVE
THERAPY.
90% PROTECTION FROM PROGRESSION
TO HOSPITALIZATIONS AND DEATH.
>> YES, AND THE DEFENSE
PRODUCTION ACT THAT YOU MENTION
THERE HAD IS WHERE THE
GOVERNMENT CAN COMPEL PRIVATE
COMPANIES TO HELP THEM RAMP UP
PRODUCTION OF SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
I DO WONDER, WE ARE APPROACHING
NEW YEAR'S EVE AT THE END OF
THIS WEEK.
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE GOT EVENT
AND GATHERINGS PLANNED.
I KNOW YOU SAID IT'S OKAY TO BE
WITH FRIENDS AND FAMILY IF
YOU'RE VACCINATED AND BOOSTED
BUT WHAT IS YOUR ADVICE TO
PEOPLE ABOUT LARGER SETTINGS FOR
NEW YEAR'S PARTIES?
>> KAITLYN, I WOULD STAY AWAY
FROM THAT.
I HAVE BEEN TELLING PEOPLE
CONSISTENTLY THAT IF YOU'RE
VACCINATED AND BOOSTED AND YOU
HAVE A FAMILY SETTING IN THE
HOME WITH FAMILY AND RELATIVES
BUT WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A
NEW YEAR'S EVE PARTY, WE HAVE
30, 40, 50 PEOPLE CELEBRATING,
YOU DO NOT KNOW THE STATUS OF
THEIR VACCINATION, I WOULD
RECOMMEND STRONGLY STAY AWAY
FROM THAT THIS YEAR.
THERE WILL BE OTHER YEARS TO DO
THAT, BUT NOT THIS YEAR.
>> NOT THIS YEAR, THAT'S GOOD
INFORMATION.
I DO HAVE ONE MORE QUESTION FOR
YOU.
YOU ARE AN ADVISER TO PRESIDENT
BIDEN NOW, OF COURSE.
YOU PREVIOUSLY WERE AN ADVISER
WHEN IT CAME TO PRESIDENT TRUMP
WHEN HE WAS IN OFFICE IN THE
BEGINNING OF THIS PANDEMIC, AND
YOU'VE SEEN SURELY BY NOW THIS
EXCHANGE THAT HE HAD WITH
CANDACE OWENS TALKING ABOUT THE
TRUTH ON VACCINES AND BOOSTERS
AND HOW IT CAN KEEP PEOPLE OUT
OF THE HOSPITAL FROM DYING.
I'M WONDERING WHAT YOU MADE OF
THAT, GIVEN IT'S BEEN THIS
RIGHT-WING BACKLASH EVER SINCE
THE FORMER PRESIDENT MADE THOSE
COMMENTS?
>> WELL, I MEAN, I'M GLAD THAT
THE FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
NOW TALKING ABOUT WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT TO GET VACCINATED.
I WAS STUNNED BY THE FACT THAT'S
DOING THAT, AND HE'S GETTING
BOOED IN SOME PLACES FOR DOING
THAT, WHICH MEANS THAT YOU KNOW,
POISONING THE WELL EARLY ON
ABOUT, EVEN NOT BEING
ENTHUSIASTIC OR OUTRIGHT NOT
PUSHING VACCINES AND
DISCOURAGING VACCINES NOW HAS
THE LINGERING EFFECT AND EVEN
WHEN YOU COME OUT AND SAY GO GET
VACCINATED, SOME OF THE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING HIS
EVERY WORD AND WHAT HE DOES ARE
NOW PUSHING BACK AND NOT
LISTENING, WHICH IS, REALLY
TELLS YOU THE STRENGTH OF THE
DIVISIVENESS IN OUR SOCIETY
WHICH I'VE ALWAYS SAID TO ME IS
THE BIGGEST STUMBLING BLOCK
ABOUT GETTING THIS PANDEMIC
UNDER CONTROL.
IT REALLY IS NO PLACE FOR
DIVISIVENESS POLITICALLY WHEN
YOU HAVE A CLASSICAL HISTORICAL
UNPRECEDENTED PANDEMIC.
IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
>> MILLIONS OF AMERICANS STILL
UNVACCINAT